hey leute und willkommen zum ersten
kontakt wo ich hier so ein gameplay im
hintergrund gelegt habe also ich hab ja
schon ein oder zwei kontakten ich
gemacht aber das ist jetzt der erste wo
ich wirklich so ein hunger games
gameplay hinter gelegt habe und zwar
habe ich das auf dem server von narnia
mellon erspielt die ip findet er eine
beschreibung also wenn ihr da auch drauf
gehen wollt blabla da werde ich
wahrscheinlich jetzt in zukunft immer so
meine gameplay er spielen für den
kontakt und zwar ja ich hab das ja auf
facebook gesagt dass ich immer so ein
paar gameplay zu hinterlegen werde und
heutiges thema ist einfach so die
entwicklung von meinem kanal sag ich mal
bzw die entwicklung von microsoft in der
youtube szene beziehungsweise meine
geschmäcker und so weiter also da möchte
ich ein bisschen drüber reden und auch
sowie das zurzeit bei mir ist somit zeit
und warum so wenig uploads und so weiter
also das werde ich heute alles so mit
euch bequatschen ich glaube ich werde
das gameplay hintergrund ein bisschen
schneller vorspielen
weil das gameplay geht an sich zwölf
minuten und ich weiß nicht ob ich zwölf
minuten über das thema quatschen werde
sonst keine ahnung was normal ich weiß
nicht ich habe das gameplay übrigens nun
hintergrund gepackt damit dem wissen was
zu gucken gehabt während ich hier so ein
bisschen quatschen und ja also ich muss
euch erst mal ein bisschen über meinen
kanal erzählen und zwar habe ich ja vor
einem jahr ziemlich genau diesen kanal
hier angefangen crafter hat nur mit
minecraft angefangen hab es ja auch
taucht auch 90 prozent nur minecraft
gemacht dann noch mal ein bisschen happy
will zwischendurch ein paar andere
spieler gemacht sich aber mittlerweile
wieder gelöscht habe weil ich daran dann
doch nicht lizenzen hatte
und naja jedenfalls hat mit minecraft
immer richtig richtig viel spaß gemacht
weil es gab halt zur kompletten
möglichkeiten von wegmann konnte
adventure web spielen konnte mods
vorstellen spotlights finde ich richtig
richtig geil und so was alles so wenn
wir nicht zu sachen vorstellt nur
mittlerweile ist bei mir so dass ich
mein kreft wirklich nur noch spieler sag
ich mal wenn ich auch wirklich aufnehmen
damals war es so bei mir ich hab
minecraft auch so gespielt mit freunden
oder hält auch alleine mehr einer welt
daran herumgebastelt wie man das halt so
als normaler spieler von einem spiel was
man gerne mal hat das spielt man halt
manchmal und bei minecraft ist es bei
mir so ich möchte es nicht mehr so in
der freizeit spielen da spiele ich
lieber irgendwie keine ahnung tv oder
cod oder
allgemein wenn ich mal zeit habe dann
auch wenn schon zur zeit wirklich fifa
11 ultimate team also das regal
jedenfalls ist es bei mir zurzeit so
dass ich wirklich auf meinen kreft nicht
so viel bock hat deswegen lade ich
gerade so die videos hoch die ich in den
letzten tagen beziehungsweise auch vor
einer woche haben wir martina challenger
aufgenommen wo vor zwei wochen das lade
ich zurzeit hat wirklich alles noch hoch
und dann startet ja bald das an
weihnachten also am ersten dezember
kommt jeden tag ein video von mir wo ich
in einer schneewelt ich denke alleine
irgendetwas bauen werde und über
spezielle themen dann immer über in
einer folge über spezielle über ein
spezielles thema an weihnachten
quatschen werde während ich dann dort in
dieser welt da irgendwas bauer also
jeden tag 15 minuten und ihr könnt mir
dann doch immerhin so in die kommentare
schreiben
jedenfalls es bei mir zurzeit so dass
ich wirklich nicht so viel lust auf
minecraft habe sondern hauptsächlich
fifa spiele und da habe ich mich auch
mit jener so halbwegs drüber unterhalten
nachdem wir oder bevor wir die
theatershow folgen 36 bis 40 aufgenommen
haben also da wo wir alleine waren und
das komische häuschen da gebaut haben
ihr habt ihr schon die eine folge jetzt
gesehen bzw heute wenn ihr das video
steht glaube ich müsste oder gestern ich
weiß gar nicht wann dieses video ankommt
jedenfalls habe ich mich mit ihm
unterhalten
und da hat er mich gefragt hey du willst
du wirklich später oder dass man jetzt
auch schon games die nicht minecraft
sind also fifa cod und so wirklich auf
den zweit kanal bringen weil ich meinen
also der stadt jena gesagt ja egal wie
auch zu den erwähnten oder so das
abonnierte keiner und dann habe ich
gesagt ich weiß es ist also eine
notlösung weil ich hab ihr hier auf
kontraste mal andere spieler hochgeladen
und das kam natürlich sehr schlecht an
also die bewertungen deutlich negativ
weil alle sind hier beim einem kanal
wegen minecraft das wäre genauso als
wenn sagen wir grund der nur gaming
macht auf seinem kanal schwingt
tutorials machen würde natürlich nicht
so krass das sind immer noch spiele sage
ich mal was ich mache aber ihr seid halt
nur wegen minecraft hier sag ich mal 60
tausend leute sind glaube ich
mittlerweile sind alle nur wegen
minecraft ich sagen okay 50.000 sind
vielleicht nur noch aktiv weil
zehntausende irgendwie kanal geschlossen
und nur alle fünf wochen man youtube
oder so keine ahnung
50.000 leute sind nur wenn microsoft
hier und wollen nur minecraft sehen und
deswegen bekommt einfach bei mir auch
immer so 10.000 klicks
ihr könnt nicht davon aus den at doch
das video klickt vor allem weil die zab
box voll auf drum spendabler
jedenfalls würde denke ich wenn ich ein
anderes spiel hochladen würde dass hier
nur sage ich tausend klicks bekommen
dass die klicks mir nicht wichtig aber
die bewertung sind wir wichtig und die
kommentare das habe ich schon sehr oft
gesagt und zwar kommentar eigentlich am
meisten da wurde mir mal so gesagt als
ich dann zum beispiel web hochgeladen
habe ich doch dass der minecraft offene
kanal blablabla hätte dann ohne
schlechte bewertung
jedenfalls wollte ich euch nur sagen
dass ich ihn gefragt habe einfach mal so
aus jux und laune haye könnte mir
vielleicht eine bildungs erklärung geben
oder als halt schon vermeldet dass jetzt
gerade so dass ihr dann nicht ins bein
schlaf wenn ich das sofort holen wird
und die so jung
hier hat eine duldung erklärung ich so
dasteht aber drin bleibt mit meinem
vater durch gegen eine steht drin dass
sich die mich monetarisieren darf man
diese ja wir haben die falsche gesendet
hier die hier bekommt spezielle leute
damit könnte auf - monetarisieren bleibt
euch gesagt okay cool danke also erst
recht ganz locker
die haben jetzt die lizenzen an
battlefield an mafia an fifa an alle
spiele von ea haben die lizenzen gegeben
und ich dachte jetzt quasi hier auf
kontraste hochladen die sache ist
einfach ich darf die spieler auf
kontraste hochladen nicht auf kunst log
datei ist also ihr müsst euch mal alltag
so vorstellen ich komme aus der schule
irgendwie noch sport sagen wir dann noch
fahrstuhl oder sohn michael zu hause und
dann spiele ich eigentlich meistens nur
noch am ziel vorbei ich keine lust hat
mir aufnehmen sondern einfach nur noch
ein bisschen chillen wird fifa spielen
will und ich bin bei ultimate team
mittlerweile so mittelmäßig sag ich mal
sich ab jetzt an die leute die es
interessiert ich habe pizarro ich habe
thomas müller ich hab es wein adler also
insgesamt die von 100 ungefähr dem
bewertung 80 oder so also wirklich
mittelmaß ich hab noch könnte ich habe
da kein geld rein investiert also alles
mir selbst erspielt oder so war es auch
jetzt egal jedenfalls macht das halt
immer ganz spaß das zu spielen und dann
zieht auch immer ein paar packs und so
und das soll man ganz witzig was ich da
dann für für ich sag mal für reaktionen
und für emotionen auch zeige während ich
da dann tore kassiere oder tore mache
und das habe ich jetzt ich hab' mir so
eine elgato game capture karte gekauft
das habe ich bei facebook gepostet und
die sache ist die
da ich nun die lizenzen habe an fifa
duffys hochladen unter ihnen auch die
möglichkeit haben durch die elgato
töchter spielern durch den fernseher und
durch den pc und alles mittlerweile kann
ich es auch hochladen also ich könnte
theoretisch wie ver gameplays bringen
und die sache ist die ich habe einmal
eine frage bei facebook gemacht ob man
noch fifa von mir will
da wollte ich einfach nur ganz kurz
gucken die ersten leute die abgestimmt
haben einfach nur ganz kurz danach
wieder gelöscht und zwar war es deutlich
negativ wenn mir ist es allerdings so
dass fifa zurzeit das einzige spiel ist
was wir wirklich spaß macht und damit
überhaupt noch mehr videos von mir
bekommt also minecraft wird nicht runter
geschraubt das jetzt einfach noch fifa
oben drauf gepackt
ich möchte dass nämlich auch mal film
und da möchte ich dadurch leicht auf 1 2
kanal nicht darf all dies wenn hier
hochladen
das heißt ja ich werde demnächst fifa
hochladen darauf wollte ich euch nun
schon mal vorbereiten
ich sags mal so und zwar war das bei den
er damals auch seinen kanal gemacht habe
mit tony minecraft angefangen hat dann
gesagt leute das geht nicht nur mit
minecraft da wird die community nachher
hier bei meinem kanal so werden von
wegen dass er voll blöd dass du als
andere spiele machst und so deswegen
wollte ganz früh anfang mit auch anderen
spielen und den zeitpunkt nämlich
verpennt also ich hab jetzt bin total
froh für meine ganze fenster 60.000
leute die ganz große menge fußball
stadion voll und ich möchte euch einfach
sagen bitte seid nicht allzu streng mit
mir wenn ich daran fifa hochladen
ignoriert ist einfach wenn ihr nur
minecraft sehen wollten mich wird's
natürlich freuen wenn ich trotzdem
anguckt und trotzdem entscheidet ob es
gut findet oder nicht
ich denke bei mir ist vielfach anders
als bei solchen anderen langweiligen
kommentatoren die das machen weil ich da
schon ein paar mal ausrastet
naja in diesem video wollte ich euch nur
sagen dass demnächst auf jeden fall mehr
videos kommen werden weil ich habe mir
hier schon mit zurechtgelegt ich jetzt
nicht vorlesen 12345 mods habe ich mir
schon auf dem desktop gezogen die für
den 1.2 sind nur noch vorstellen muss
ich hab noch 42 sieht die beide von
meiner facebook seite sind also da gucke
ich jetzt eigentlich hauptsächlich noch
sein vater ein schreiben also in zukunft
werden nicht viele videos kommt vor
allem im dezember kommt vom ersten bis
zum 24 jeden tag sondern komisch ist
hier christmas video und zwischendurch
kommt dann immer fifa also mich würd's
auf jeden fall freuen wenn du da nicht
allzu streng sag ich mal jetzt nicht
allzu so von wegen
du machst fifa die totale hingabe aber
ich hab einfach total bock auf dieses
spiel und ich hab auch box aufzunehmen
und box hochzuladen von daher ich könnte
jetzt sagen es ist mein kanal das ist
mir scheißegal was er dazu sagt julians
blogs tel
aber ich möchte eigentlich auch immer
eure meinung einholen und ich weiß dass
viele sagen denn das ist voll blöd aber
ich möchte einfach dass ihr euch das
erste oder die ersten videos von fifa
einfach mal ansehen und dann selbst
entscheidet ob jetzt gut findet oder
nicht gut findet weiter dann vielleicht
ein paar sachen mit freunden machen wenn
wir packs open open links machen vor
allem letzteres gezogen das werde übels
abgegangen bzw eigentlich nur ich weil
der kauf 7 pack für 7500 und christin
dafür 30.000 wieder verkaufen kein
fairplay sie ja egal
das wollte ich euch in diesem video
einfach nur sagen dass ich demnächst
auch fifa machen werde
jeder nicht allzu streng mit mir sein
bett und bitte nicht beschweren dass
zurzeit zu wenig videos kommen weil ich
habe echt wenig zeit das ist bei allen
so zurzeit die noch zur schule gehen
dass die wenig hochladen
ich denke da bin ich nicht der einzige
ich denke ich könnte auch ganz viele
andere wieder auf zurzeit sagen jaja
aber über wenig zeit was hochzuladen und
vor allem jetzt auch von wegen schule
und alles also hat man echt wenig zeit
also die themenliste was ich jetzt tue
gesagt habe will ich sagen
nächster konto kommt irgendwann nächste
woche oder so wenn ich das schaffe zu
halten und dann wieder mit einem neuen
thema was sich allerdings jetzt schon
weiß und dann sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wie immer wenn es euch da konnte
auch gefallen hat würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr einen daumen hoch gibt und zwar
wenn wir in die 500 daumen hoch schaffen
oder so dass wir auf jeden fall ganz neu
war daran sehe ich dass es euch gefallen
hat und ihr seht dass es euch auch
gefallen hat und so weiter und so fort
und wir sind beide switches sie genau
zehn minuten